Let's go next to let me go to Kenny in Phenix.
Kenny in Phenix, you're on the air.
Good morning, David.
How are you?
I'm good, how are you doing?
Good eating breakfast or not?
All right.
What are you having?
Some bacon, some eggs and toast with butter.
Oh, my goodness, turkey bacon, I'm sure, right?
No, sir.
Unfortunately, the full thing, OK.
Very, very good.
Oh yeah.
So I wanted to ask I actually had a conversation
with a really good friend of mine that I've
had since early childhood.
And last night I had a conversation with him
about politics and we've never talked about
it before.
I consume a lot of political content.
And, you know, he I think this kind of ties
into the whole, like, deprogramming thing,
so I was talking to him and he he thoroughly
believes all the talking points, but he doesn't
consume any media.
I asked him about it.
He doesn't really watch the media.
He doesn't really read any news.
He knows all this stuff through word of mouth,
which is kind of scary.
Now, when you say word of mouth, you mean
like literally do you mean people at work
telling him or are you including social media
and word of mouth?
Um, I think social media actually might play
a role.
Right.
But, yeah, I was that's that's I think the
key thing, because at this point, you know,
when we talk about like Fox News, for example,
only a few million people are ever watching
any particular episode of Fox News.
This country has three hundred and thirty
one million people.
But the point is Fox News has agenda setting
power.
And then you see the stories repeated on Facebook
and on Twitter, et cetera.
And that's where it's being.
That's where it's being repeated.
And that makes sense.
Yeah.
And so so we were going back and forth about
the election fraud thing, and I kept trying
to I don't think he really understood, you
know, how all this stuff works.
And I think, you know, I think a lot of people
don't.
Yeah.
Like what?
What do you think?
And it was it was so hard to, you know, be
polite.
Right.
Because as someone who's paying attention
to this stuff, it's like it's it's it's really
frustrating, you know?
So I guess what I just wanted to pick your
brain and see, like, what do you think maybe
some strategies might be like?
I guess, like Comley, you know, attack this.
I guess.
I mean, with someone that's that uninformed
and who's basically just getting what other
people they know are sharing on Facebook,
for example, they're not even necessarily
it's not even about getting them to look at
different news outlets because they're not
even looking at news.
You have to start really softly with where
where did you where did you learn that?
And getting them to say and then say, oh,
and how do you know that that's trustworthy?
You know, they say, well, my aunt, Aunt Beatrice,
shared it on Facebook.
OK, well, what what does Aunt Beatrice do
for work?
Oh, well, I don't know.
She works in a factory.
All right.
So clearly she got it from somewhere.
She this wasn't her research.
Where did she get it?
Well, I guess I don't know where she got it.
OK, well, you know, you can you can find out
for yourself.
There are primary sources on this stuff.
You've got to start getting them open to the
idea that they may be hearing things that
aren't true.
But it is it's really tough.
It's very, very difficult.
Yeah, it can be really hard when, like one
thing I think a lot of people in the right
tend to do is like they'll do all their own
research and they'll end up in a lot of very
interesting conclusions.
Right.
But research often just means you look at
articles on Breitbart, you know.
Yeah, pretty much.
Right.
And then it's like, well, I can come back
at them with ten articles that say, hey, you're
not right, man.
Yeah, well, you can't believe everything you
read on the Internet.
And it's just like, oh man, this.
Yeah, it can be a little stressful.
I mean, the problem is that with a lot of
these things, you know, there's this false
notion that it's up to sort of like opinion,
like, for example, just cutting taxes for
the rich, help the economy.
That's an empirical question.
And we can look in history at changes to tax
rates and then the associated changes in GDP,
employment, et cetera.
There's a lot of people who, unfortunately,
are in the paradigm of, well, I don't know,
because, you know, the nation says one thing
and Breitbart says a different thing.
And then Tucker says one thing, but then MSNBC
says something else.
You can go and look at economic papers that
are peer reviewed from, you know, groups of
economists and actually answered that question.
But the problem is, a lot of people either
aren't aware or don't know or have the interest
in actually doing that.
But a lot of these things are really they're
knowable, they're not really opinion.
They're not really up for debate.
Yeah, so I guess I guess like a big first
step is going to be trying to, I guess, get
like.
Get these people to understand that academics
have what is it like?
Like they're held accountable, it has accountability.
Yeah, and I think the first step is just getting
people to recognize that there's limits to
what they know.
If once people recognize that their their
knowledge is limited and there's more out
there, that's step one.
And unfortunately, a lot of people are either
just naturally incurious or are just busy
living their lives where they take that thing
they see on Facebook.
And that's as far as they go.
And that's that's that's not a good recipe.
Yeah, that makes Kenny great to hear from
you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right.
We're going to take a quick break.
If you're holding to talk to me, please don't
hang up because we're going right back to
the phones momentarily.